MARTIN GORNER: Hello,
and welcome back
on Root Access Berlin.
We are here again at
the factory studio
for the second episode
on SQL versus NoSQL.
I have with me Nacho Coloma
from the company Koliseo.
So first of all, tell us
again what Koliseo is.
NACHO COLOMA: Koliseo
is a ticketing platform
that is focused on making
the ticketing experience as
simple and as fast as possible.
MARTIN GORNER: Now we would
like to hear your expert advice
on how to work around some
of the limitations of NoSQL
databases.
What are the tips,
tricks, and what
is the secret sauce
that you use at Koliseo?
NACHO COLOMA: Yeah,
in the last episode
we were talking
about the difference
between SQL and NoSQL databases.
Today we are going
to focus on tricks.
How do you work around
the limitations?
MARTIN GORNER: In the
process of building Koliseo,
you acquired a lot of expertise
on App Engine and the data
store, and you are publishing
this library called SimpleDS,
which makes it easier to
work with the data store
because it provides a
mapping between Java classes
and Datastore entities.
NACHO COLOMA:
Yeah, that's right.
It's available at
GitHub and also there's
a lot of introductory
materials to SimpleDS.
So I invite everyone
to try it out.
MARTIN GORNER: And so the
alternatives to SimpleDS.
So JPA and JDO, that's what
the documentation says.
NACHO COLOMA: Yeah.
And Objectify is
what a lot of people
are using also these days.
MARTIN GORNER: But
I think we agree
that people are better off using
either Objectify or SimpleDS.
NACHO COLOMA: Yeah.
Yeah, you should try to
shy away from JDO or JPA
because they are too
generalistic solutions.
They are focused
on SQL databases
and the NoSQL problems
are extremely different.
MARTIN GORNER: So
we came up lost time
with this five point
list for helping
people decide between
SQL and NoSQL.
We've seen that on
the scalability front,
NoSQL is unbeatable.
That also a lot of people
feel that a NoSQL database
can represent their data in a
more natural way, although that
is a philosophical discussion.
But in the SQL world, you have
the power all the SQL language.
How do you work with
queries in NoSQL?
NACHO COLOMA: If you are
trying to execute a query,
you need to have an index for
every field that is involved,
for every property that
is involved in that query.
MARTIN GORNER: Let's take
the example of a ticket
that we store as an entity
in a NoSQL data store.
And well, first of
all, I want to find
all of the tickets that
belong to a given event.
So my ticket has an event key.
NACHO COLOMA: Yeah.
MARTIN GORNER: But I need
to do something extra
to be able to query by that key.
NACHO COLOMA: First of
all, if you are only
asking for tickets
with a 13 event key
in the App Engine Data Store,
all properties in an entity
are by default indexed.
You have a single index.
You have an index for a single
property that is the event key.
If you are only
going to ask give me
all the tickets
with this event key,
you can have that
out of the box.
MARTIN GORNER: But still,
it costs me storage.
NACHO COLOMA: Yeah.
Yeah, every index that is
stored with your entities
takes a space and it
takes performance as well.
So at some point, you
will almost certainly
have more space dedicated to
indexes than to the information
itself.
MARTIN GORNER: And
so what do I need
to do now if I want to
query by two properties?
Like here for instance I want
to get all the tickets relating
to this event and then sort
them by their creation date,
for instance.
NACHO COLOMA: Yeah.
Not only when you are querying
by a property, also when you
are sorting, you need
an index for that.
When you are doing it with
more than one property
at the same time, you need
to create a composite index.
MARTIN GORNER: And so
this multiple index
will also cost me, of
course, storage space.
NACHO COLOMA: Yeah.
MARTIN GORNER: So what are the
storage space saving tricks
that you can recommend?
For instance, you told
me that for some requests
you might want to filter
in memory instead of asking
the Datastore to do
the filtering for you.
NACHO COLOMA: Yeah.
There are several
possibilities here.
First of all, if you want, you
can disable automatic indexing
for single properties.
If you know for sure
that a property is never
going to be used in
the query, then you
can just store it as an
index and it will not
take that extra space.
Another case that we are finding
a lot, when you have a query
and you are reasonably sure
that the criteria for selecting
is 99% of the time going to
be a match for your query,
then you can do that in memory.
For example, in this
case we are executing
a query of all the
users with certain role.
Now we're only interested
in users that are enabled.
You can add that and
use a composite index.
That's a waste because 99%
of your users are enabled.
This is, in this case, you
can assume that it's not
frequent to find disabled users.
In that case, what
we are doing here,
we're using Guava
predicates to filter.
This is a filtering
that is done in memory.
This query will return
you a paginated query.
And before returning you the
list of data for this page,
it's going to filter
in memory according
to predicated you have passed.
A predicate is a function
that is inside Guava.
Guava is one library that
is from Google, actually,
an open source
library, that allows
you to manipulate
collections of data.
So in this case,
what we are doing
is to filter and return only
users that are not disabled.
MARTIN GORNER:
Another problem you
told me about is that
in the NoSQL world,
you don't have joins.
NACHO COLOMA: Yeah, and
that's a problem actually,
because if you want to show
data from two different entities
at the same time, you can do
that as you would with SQL.
It's a no brainer.
You have two entities.
You want to put one
along the other.
You just make a join and
everything's working.
MARTIN GORNER: So for
instance, here you
want to show a list of users.
And next to each user, you
want to display his last post.
NACHO COLOMA: Yep.
MARTIN GORNER: So that would
be a join in the SQL world.
NACHO COLOMA: That's right.
You have two different
entities and you
want to put one
beside the other.
MARTIN GORNER: So the simple
solution that I would implement
would be something like this.
I would run a query to
return all of my articles.
And then for each article,
I would run a separate query
to return its author.
NACHO COLOMA: Yeah.
MARTIN GORNER: Why
is that a bad idea?
NACHO COLOMA: This is the
typical first approach
to this problem.
You have the list
of articles and then
you're going to
ask for each user
over and over and over again.
What happens is that each
time you go to the Datastore
it's an expensive operation in
terms of CPU, in terms of time.
And you are making these
calls sequentially,
one after the other.
So if, for example,
you have 20 articles,
they're going to request
20 times to the Datastore
to get the users back.
Instead of that, the approach
that you should try to do
is to process all the
articles, get all the keys,
and then require all the
users in a single request.
MARTIN GORNER: So here we are
assuming that our articles
inside of the article, you
have a user key that is stored.
And so you get the articles,
you get the collection of keys,
and then the Datastore has a
built in functionality which
is called batch
queries where you
can provide this
list of keys and it
will return a list of uers.
NACHO COLOMA: You
can request I want
to get all these keys
in a single operation
and it will get back.
You don't have to do
anything special for that.
That's a good thing
of NoSQL storage,
that you can ask
for a set of keys
and they will come
back right away.
MARTIN GORNER: So
let's look at the code
here for executing this.
So the red line here
is what I understand.
I call the Datastore.
I give it a bunch of keys and
in return I get a map of users.
NACHO COLOMA: What
we have here is
we are retrieving the articles,
then we're transforming again,
we're using Guava for these.
We're transforming
all the articles
into their use of keys.
MARTIN GORNER: And so
here simply instead of
doing an integration
you use this trick that
looks like functional
programming that
comes with Guava where you can
provide a mapping function that
returns a user key
from an article entity.
NACHO COLOMA: That's right.
Entity to property
function is something
that comes with SimpleDS.
SimpleDS has several
tricks like these
to make easy the
functional programming
part of working with NoSQL.
Because these are cases
that go over and over again.
When you're working,
you're always faking joins,
you are always
filtering memory because
of the limitations
in the platform.
So SimpleDS is
designed to help you
with that, trying
to make it easier.
MARTIN GORNER: So we
went through the art,
I would say, the black art
of querying the Datastore.
Another limitation
that is quite painful,
frankly, is the lack
of database schemas.
Some people like very strict
schemas and some people
like the freedom that a
NoSQL database offers.
But it also means that
in a NoSQL database
you will have to maintain
the integrity or your data
structures basically by hand.
NACHO COLOMA: Yep.
Say, for example, that
you want to add new fields
to an existing structure
then [INAUDIBLE]
another table right?
You would just add a column
and it's already there.
And maybe you can also
assign a default value
and it's already initialized.
You don't have to do
anything special for that.
MARTIN GORNER: So that would
be one operation in a SQL
database.
NACHO COLOMA: That's right.
That's right.
But not in NoSQL.
In NoSQL you don't
have any schema,
meaning that every
instance is independent.
If you want to add
the property and you
want it to exist in all
the existing instances
in the Datastore, then you
have to execute that by hand.
You have to go one by
one adding the property,
then installing
the instance, going
to the next one, et
cetera, et cetera.
MARTIN GORNER: So let's
stop a minute here.
You told me before that I
can do any full table scans
because only index
queries are going to work.
But here I need
to go through all
of my entities of
the whole Datastore
to upgrade them to
my new data model.
NACHO COLOMA: Yeah.
You can do that using cursors.
Cursors work in
NoSQL more or less
the same way they
do in SQL databases.
You have a big set
of data to process.
You can use cursors to
postpone work, to say,
OK, I stopped here and I want to
restart this query again later.
So you can work in chunks of
work and keep postponing work.
So let's say, for example, one
common practice when you're
working with NoSQL Datastores
is to denormalize your data.
We were talking about how
you had different collections
of articles and
users and you wanted
to transform your
articles into users.
But if your operation is,
say, executing 80% of the time
because, for example, it's part
of your home page or whatever,
it's happening and over again.
What you usually do
in NoSQL databases
is to denormalize data.
To get into the
article the fields
that I need from the user
for 80% of the cases.
MARTIN GORNER: So that's what
we see here in this example.
I added into my article
entity those three red fields,
username, user
email, user avatar,
that are duplicated
from the user entity.
NACHO COLOMA: Yeah.
And you will have to
keep those by hand.
If the user is
modified, you will
have to cascade these changes to
all the articles by that user.
But the thing is, how
do you introduce this
into an already
working database,
into your already
working application?
With a new upgrade, you need to
modify your data to denormalize
it and it's going to apply
to all the existing articles.
So you have to
modify all of them.
MARTIN GORNER: Let's
see an example.
I understand the code here.
I understand the three
red lines in the middle.
That is where we are setting
the username, the email,
and the avatar on the
article coming from the user.
I also understand that we
have a for loop around this.
we are doing an iteration
of all of our articles.
And actually the
first red line, that
is a query that is returning
all of my articles.
But of course, this is going
to be a lot of articles.
NACHO COLOMA: Yeah, and
you have limitations
that you should always
be aware of in appending.
In appending, all requests
should be ending by 30 seconds.
You can be executing
in a back end
or you could be executing
in a query, in a task queue.
But in any of these
cases, your query
has an expiration
time of 30 seconds.
So if you're going to execute a
long running query because you
have to process
a lot of results,
you should be stopping
after some time
and retasking again,
rescheduling your remaining
work.
MARTIN GORNER: And
so the problem here
is that you need to know when
you query's about to time out.
So you're using a
different library
which has this query
time out function.
But then once you stop
processing your articles,
and you know that you have
not finished, how are you
resuming this operation?
NACHO COLOMA: In
this case, what we're
doing is the return a cursor.
If you're returning
a NotNode cursor,
then I assume that
you have not finished.
So I reschedule
to execute again,
or I just call it
right away again
because I have enough time.
MARTIN GORNER: So you are
you're putting that cursor
into a task which you are
putting onto the task queue
again.
And it will be executed
at a later point in time.
But you need all that to be
finished before you upload
the new version of
your software that
is using those no new fields.
NACHO COLOMA: That's right.
That's right.
You should design
this kind of task
to be unimportant in the sense
that you can execute them
over and over again
and it would work.
Or you can also work with
MapReduce if you want.
That's going to be
faster on one side.
On the other side, it's going
to be a bit more complicated
to configurate.
Your choice.
MARTIN GORNER: The last point
that I would like us to discuss
is coherence.
You have a very good example of
that using events and tickets.
So first of all,
tell us why you need
a transaction to buy a ticket.
NACHO COLOMA: When you
are buying a ticket,
you need transactions
in NoSQL data
stores the same way you
need them in SQL databases.
You need to change
two entities and they
have to behave transactionally.
Either the two of them
are modified or not.
An event has the number
of available tickets.
Let's say, for
example, one hand when
I am buying a ticket I
am creating a new entity
and you want that to
behave transactionally.
I want to reduce the number
of available tickets,
I want to create
my ticket, and that
has to happen both of them or
neither at all, nothing at all.
So in that case, what you do
is to create your transaction,
make all your modifications,
and commit or rollback
the transaction.
MARTIN GORNER: But
in order to do that,
I need to have my event and
my tickets in the same entity
group or at least I needed to
until App Engine implemented
cross group transactions.
NACHO COLOMA:
Yeah, that's right.
It's more flexible
and now you can
make cross group transactions,
[INAUDIBLE] transactions
that can put up to five
different entity groups
in the same transactions.
MARTIN GORNER: But you
say this is not actually
a good way of organizing
things because we
have a write limit of something
like one to five writes
per second to the
same entity group.
It means that only a
maximum of five people
can be trying to buy the
same ticket at the same time.
And so the quantities that you
are handling in real events
are way larger than that.
NACHO COLOMA:
Yeah, that's right.
So another option, more
realistic to apply entity
groups, because not all
master detail relationships
are suitable for entity groups.
But we had a similar
case for users.
Now what we are doing
with this, the good thing
is that the user
is not that fast
interacting with the system.
So if you want to make a
transaction between the user
and his tickets,
for example, if you
want to keep a counter
on the number of tickets
that the user has
purchased over time,
you can do that transactionally.
And you have the guarantee
that the user is not
going to be clicking that fast.
So for that, [INAUDIBLE]
is reasonable.
MARTIN GORNER: That is that
they're good rule of thumb,
that it's a good idea to
organize the elements relating
to your users into
entity groups,
because one user is
not likely to be buying
so many tickets
at the same time.
But this still allows a
lot of different users
to be hammering the system
at the same time in hundreds
and thousands.
NACHO COLOMA: That's right.
You usually don't have
contention on the user level.
You have it somewhere else.
But a single user
is not that fast
interacting with the system.
MARTIN GORNER: And so here for
the relationship between a user
and a ticket, you group
those into an entity group.
So you can do your
transactions easily there.
And if we come back to events
and tickets, as you said,
you do not put them in
the same entity group,
because that would limit
the number of tickets
you can sell per second.
NACHO COLOMA: It's going
to be more complicated
than that, because
a contention is not
an easy problem in any case.
It's not something that you
can solve with transactions
so easily.
But these are more or less
the typical two cases.
You can choose to make an entity
group around your transactions,
or you can choose to keep your
entities separate, for example,
if you don't have-- and
because as I told you,
parent, all your entities
can have at most one parent.
So maybe your transactions
don't feed into that model
and then you have to use
cross group transactions.
Those are your two
options with App Engine.
MARTIN GORNER: Thank you, Nacho.
Thank you for these tips and
tricks on using the data store.
NACHO COLOMA: Thank you.
MARTIN GORNER: And
we will see you
in the next episode
of Root Access Berlin.
Thank you.